France 24 et RFI présente
[Musique]
bonjour à tous merci de nous rejoindre
pour ici l'Europe en cette semaine
marqué par une Europe qui tende des
offensives diplomatiques mais essaye
aussi de relancer son économie et pour
en parler nous prenons la direction de
La Haye au Pays-Bas nous allons y
rejoindre la vice-première ministre du
gouvernement de coalition entre quatre
parties du libéral marc-routeux il
s'agit de 6 gris CARG bonjour madame KAG
vous êtes depuis 2021 la ministre des
Finances néerlandaises première femme à
diriger le trésor dans ce pays qui mène
le groupe des États européens partisans
de la frugalité budgétaire précédemment
vous étiez d'ailleurs ministre des
Affaires étrangères vous êtes chef de
démocrates 66 partie de centre gauche et
vous vous présentez certes comme économe
mais surtout comme une Européenne
convaincue alors en cela à la visite du
président français Emmanuel Macron et de
son épouse Brigitte
très officielle visite d'État les 11 et
12 avril évidemment
c'est important pour vous et comment
est-ce que vous voyez cette France
depuis les Pays-Bas avec une grève
intense un contre la réforme des
retraites par exemple
ah oui bien sûr mais nous avons tous nos
livrons tous nos problèmes vous
connaissez peut-être aussi notre
situation actuelle par rapport à la
crise des nitrogènes mais ce qui est
important que les liens entre la France
et les Pays-Bas sont très chaleureuses
cela vaut pour marquer notre premier
ministre et le président de la
République Emmanuel Macron et pour
moi-même aussi quand je rencontre
monomologue que Bruno Le Maire et on se
on se rejoint
sur de nombreux thèmes les ambitions
climatiques au soutien apporté à la
guerre à l'Ukraine au peuple ukrainien
mais aussi bien sûr à l'unité de l'Union
européenne même politique et économique
alors Emmanuel Macron a prévu de faire
au Pays-Bas un discours sur l'avenir de
l'Europe est-ce que vous le trouvez un
petit peu trop idéologue en la matière
et parfois aussi trop dans un
tête-à-tête avec l'Allemagne qui exclut
les plus petits pays
c'est pas à moi de donner des
commentaires sur le président de la
République de France je pense c'est
important qu'il y a toujours un appli
politique de d'un pays membres autant
que pourtant que la France quand on part
de la vision pour l'Europe l'avenir de
l'Europe et nous opportunités en Europe
qui est géopolitique et en Europe qui
est géo économique il y avait des
différences importantes quand même entre
nos dpi sur la réponse à apporter au
grand plan de subventions de l'économie
durable par les États-Unis au dernier
sommet on a autorisé par exemple des
aides d'État ce qui marche bien pour les
pays européens les plus riches qui
peuvent mettre l'argent sur la table
mais pas pour les plus pauvres qui
réclament avec la France d'ailleurs un
grand plan de financement en commun on
en est où
je pense qu'il faut faire la différence
entre la réponse plutôt l'initiative
européenne lancé par Madame vanderleijn
de formuler une réponse à l'initiative
américaine en effet ça veut dire qu'il
faut que nous nous-mêmes autant que
européen
faciliteront les règles l'accès aux
règles pour les entreprises européennes
et ont même temps que nous maintenons
nous n'avons playing comment s'appelle
en anglais au même temps durant la crise
économique l'année dernière le niveau de
subventions les possibilités des États
membres ce qu'ils ont vraiment
différents pour donner un appui aux
citoyens aux entreprises vivant bien sûr
la crise énergétique et la grande le
taux d'influration qui a frappé toute
l'Europe alors les vols playfield c'est
justement des règles de concurrence non
distendues mais des règles de
concurrence non distendu entre pays
européens n'ont plus et c'est là que les
plus pauvres versus les plus les plus
riches sont peut-être un peu un peu
défavorisés dans les subventions qu'ils
peuvent accorder
oui vous avez raison dans ce sens là on
a parlé beaucoup en tant que ministre de
finance
comment on peut créer une convergence
entre les décisions qui sont prises au
niveau national qu'il faut éviter une
concurrence et en plus pour éviter qu'il
y a un grand écart entre ceux qui
peuvent permettre de soutenir leur
citoyens qui peuvent sous pensionner
beaucoup plus que d'autres pays c'est de
grands débat entre les ministres des
Finances c'est-à-dire que les Pays-Bas
nous on n'est pas convaincu que pour
chaque problème ou chaque dilemme qu'on
rencontre qu'il faut lancer un nouveau
fond mais il faut trouver toujours la
solution dans le parcours de la du
dialogue et l'unité européenne qui est
important c'est pour ça aussi qu'on
investit tellement dans la poursuite de
la réforme du parc de stabilité et
croissance voilà Marco vous avez raison
plutôt que de toujours faire des dettes
en commun mettre la main au portefeuille
à nouveau insiste sur l'argent déjà ex
du plan de relance est-ce que vous êtes
convaincu qu'il est pas il est pas tout
à fait dépensé c'est en cours nous-mêmes
aussi nous étions parmi les derniers ou
même pile le dernier pays qui qui a
réclamé l'argent pour
sous le titre de colonne je me rappelle
plus comment dire relance
nous sommes convaincus qu'il faut
toujours
l'analyse du problème l'approche
préférable et après il faut il faut
confirmer
le niveau de fond et comment
subventionner comment trouver les fonds
il y a beaucoup de fonds encore qui sont
disponibles et on en a parlé beaucoup
avec Bruno Le Maire aussi il faut
réclamer ses fonds d'abord et après on
pourra toujours discuter s'il y a
d'autres opportunités aux possibilités
ou de voir de subventionner mais il faut
traverser cette étape à notre avis alors
lors de sa visite d'État le président
Emmanuel Macron va évoquer les couples
opérations bilatérales entre la France
et les Pays-Bas elles existent dans de
nombre secteur donc des secteurs
stratégiques pour l'avenir comme la
recherche quantique notre envoyé spécial
radisja Hadjab est allé enquêter sur ce
secteur à l'aéon regarde cela pourrait
être de la science-fiction mais ici dans
la banlieue de La Haye la technologie
quantique et bien une réalité la maison
du Cantique abrite centre de recherche
universitaire et un cubateur de start-up
cuber des lundales cette société
s'intéresse à la cryptographie quantique
pour sécuriser les communications de
l'Internet de demain
la science quantique cherche à expliquer
les lois physiques qui s'appliquent à
l'infiniment petit nous parlons ici
d'électrons d'atomes de photons en
d'autres termes l'échelle unie
moléculaire
s'occuper de l'infiniment petit pour
faire des bons technologies prodigieux
l'entreprise grâce à une aide européenne
de 2 millions 700 000 euros sur les
trois prochaines années va s'agrandir et
passer de 5 à 9 chercheurs objectif
élaborer un Internet quantique mondial
fabriqué en Europe
mais au-delà le chant du quantique
pourrait aussi servir à créer de
nouveaux médicaments résoudre des
problèmes environnementaux révolutionner
les transports ici depuis cinq ans des
étudiants relèvent le défi de créer un
avion sans émission de CO2 si toutefois
on serait les premiers augmentent à
voler sur liturgiennes liquide en 2020
depuis 2 ans dans la course au quantique
la collaboration scientifique entre
chercheurs néerlandais et français
érigés au rang de priorité stratégiques
et renforcée la recherche quantique est
soutenue par l'UE à hauteur de 175
millions d'euros ces six dernières
années afin de devenir des acteurs
majeurs
nous sommes très impliqués dans nos
recherches
s'il existe un marché quantique
l'Europe a toutes les chances de
s'imposer à l'échelle mondiale
car le secteur est dominé par des
multinationales tels que IBM Google
Microsoft en d'autres termes les
États-Unis
et l'Europe doit relever un défi de
taille afin de rester en lice la fuite
des cerveaux
les États-Unis investissent 40% de plus
dans la recherche comparé à l'Europe les
start-up investissent 6 fois plus dans
l'intelligence artificielle que nous en
Europe ce ne sont pas seulement les
États-Unis mais l'Asie aussi l'Europe ne
peut pas se permettre de regarder
passivement passer le train de
l'histoire les bacs dans cette
compétition mondiale pour acquérir ces
technologies d'avenir les financements
risquent d'être la clé et l'Union
européenne entend être bien positionné
voilà madame la vice-présidente des
Pays-Bas c'est un bel exemple de
collaboration franco-néerlandaise mais
on voit aussi que l'investissement dans
la recherche et le développement est
moindre en Europe comparé aux États-Unis
ou alors à la Chine oui il y a un grand
écart il faut qu'on investisse beaucoup
plus à la recherche en tant que
gouvernement on a on a donné le priorité
aux investissements à la recherche
surtout au niveau technique vous
connaissez bien sûr les grandes sociétés
néerlandaises comme on en a en France
aussi comme la SML très connu mais il
faut faire beaucoup plus et je pense que
si la collaboration à l'échelle
européenne ou entre pays comme la France
et les Pays-Bas ou d'autres pays sera
très important pour l'avenir de l'Europe
alors depuis le covid 19 et la guerre en
Ukraine la question de notre
indépendance qui est soulevé la notre
indépendance stratégique vis-à-vis de
pays comme la Russie et la Chine se pose
est-ce que l'Union européenne se donne
les moyens de sécuriser son
approvisionnement en matière
indispensable de développer des
champions européens selon vous
je pense qu'on est sur la bonne route
mais il faut faire beaucoup plus il y a
un petit écart ou différence entre les
Pays-Bas ou la vision française et des
Pays-Bas nous soutenons une autonomie
stratégique ouverte et ce qui diffère
d'autres pays qui font vraiment
discours sur l'autonomie stratégique
nous apportons beaucoup d'importance au
libre-échange qui nous a porté beaucoup
et nous voudrions réfléchir sur la façon
selon laquelle on peut réduire les
dépendances à l'égard des premières
matières premières critique qui sont
cruciales et réinfestir et renforcer nos
fondations solides et là je pense qu'il
faut qu'on se retrouve mais nous sommes
au milieu de cette discussion et je
pense que la visite du président de la
République et Madame vanderlecht en
Chine est une visite très importante et
très critique aussi pour mener ses
discours aussi mais nous sommes
favorables discours de diwing au lieu de
dico plan comment ça s'appelle en
anglais le découpage et risqué et il
faut quand même trouver les moyens pour
faire le dérisque sans perdre tous les
atouts du libre-échange voilà ne pas se
couper par exemple d'un fournisseur
comme la Chine le libre-échange ne fait
pas tout et parfois les routes sont
coupées soit par les guerres soit par
une épidémie quand même oui tout à fait
tout à fait mais il faut il faut trouver
l'équilibre je pense qu'il faut
il faut
reconnaître que les risques du
découplage et au même temps il faut pas
qu'on soit naïve comme vous dites impact
la guerre un choix géostratégique ou
politique des adversaires politiques
alors il faut renforcer au sein de
l'Union européenne il faut soutenir des
initiatives qui ont été lancées par
Madame vanderline mais il faut trouver
les moyens aussi et il y a là je pense
que où on se retrouve sur le niveau du
débat vous avez positionner
effectivement cette visite en Chine
d'Emmanuel Macron accompagné de la
présidente de la Commission européenne
madame vanderlione volontairement il a
fait cette visite conjointe pour marquer
un exercice un peu plus européen
exercice difficile entre le risque de
dépendance économique et les questions
épineuses comme l'Ukraine est-ce que
vous attendez de la Chine qu'elle nous
soutiennent finalement sur l'Ukraine
alors je pense que l'Europe même a fait
preuve d'une solide unité en réponse à
l'agression
de Russie vers l'Ukraine il faut qu'on
maintienne ça il faut qu'on s'engage et
il faut qu'on s'exprime aussi vers
d'autres pays à un pays important comme
la Chine quels sont nos attentes et je
pense que c'est ça qu'il faut marquer à
chaque niveau et je pense qu'une unité
démontrée par la visite conjointe de du
président de la République Emmanuel
Macron et Madame vanderlin très
importante et c'est un symbole qui
passe au -delà alors vous êtes ministre
des Finances les marchés financiers
restent très nerveux avec les fondrement
de la Silicon Valley banque puis
effectivement le rachat du crédit Suisse
la patronne de la Banque centrale
européenne a conseillé de parfaire notre
union bancaire notre une onde bancaire
c'est à dire le système panaire
d'assurance des dépôts et puis des
avancées dans l'union des marchés de
capitaux pour un pays frugal comme comme
le vôtre c'est non
il y a toujours eu un long débat je
pense que on a tout à fait d'accord avec
l'appel qui a été lancé aussi par
Charles Michel vanderline et bien sûr
Christine Lagarde que j'admire beaucoup
et au même temps il faut qu'on se
concentre sur les débats qui n'ont pas
été conclus et il y a beaucoup de
détails et de diable est toujours dans
le détail mais l'importance de réaliser
d'atteindre une union bancaire je pense
que c'est très clair pour nous tous il
faut traverser maintenant les écarts
politiques et les avis qui sont
différents pour nous ce qui est
important que qu'on renforce force aussi
le cadre pour mieux gérer les crises
comme point de départ
alors vous avez un problème vous l'avez
dit si on revient à votre pays les
Pays-Bas un problème écologique de
taille avec trop d'azote dans votre sol
à cause d'un élevage très intensif vous
souhaitez le réduire de moitié d'ici
2030 mais vous n'avez pas expliqué
vraiment comment puis il y a une forte
colère finalement des fermiers montées
du Parti paysan aux dernières élections
il y a un mois à peine comment vous
sortir de cette crise écologique
autant que gouvernement on a déjà pris
on a préparé les plans comment sortir de
cette crise écologique qui atteint le
niveau de l'économie notre possibilité
de construire des maisons des bâtiments
de vraiment aussi de donner une
opportunité qui est juste et durable
pour pour les paysans de construire leur
vie dans l'avenir il y a le plan mais il
y a une forte opposition ce qui est
clair et en même temps qu'il faut qu'on
trouve la bonne solution il y a
d'adoptions on verra comment ceci et
comment ton va-t-il arriver cette grande
débat politique est très sensible comme
vous le savez oui alors justement les
parties de coalition de marque ruteux
ont reculé aux dernières élections
effectivement le taux d'approbation de
votre gouvernement est au plus bas à
20%, est-ce que vous pensez que ce
gouvernement est fragile et risque de
chuter
c'est une bonne question mais je suis
pas la bonne personne pour y répondre je
pense que quand on est entré au
gouvernement en tant que représentante
ou leader de mon parti on a toujours dit
il faut il faut il faut faire ce qui est
juste pour le pays si on arrive à un pas
on sera pas dans la capacité de de créer
ou de donner des résultats c'est un
moment
critique bien évidemment il faut qu'on
s'en sorte et on verra si on arrive
demain et juste vous qu'est-ce que vous
attendez vous du président français en
visite finalement chez vous je pense que
la vision du président de la France va
nous inspirer va nous donner à tout et
je pense aussi c'est une bon moment de
toujours donner un nouvel élan à nourrir
la Siam bilatérale qui sont déjà très
fortes et très chaleureux et harmonieux
mais des moments de visite à haut niveau
au plus haut niveau c'est toujours un
bon rappel aussi en temps de guerre sur
notre continent rappel de tous nos
atouts en partenariat et partenariat si
étroit qu'on qu'on trésor que nous
partageons avec la France merci madame
la ministre d'avoir été en notre
compagnie vous restez avec nous je
retrouve à Bruxelles ma conso de Public
Sénat pour plonger en eaux troubles et
organiser un grand débat sur la pêche
[Musique]
merci de nous rejoindre depuis Bruxelles
pas franchement au bord de la mer mais
nous allons quand même parler de ces
océans de ces ressources en poissons qui
sont en chute et puis de polémique aussi
autour des pratiques de pêche rappelons
par ailleurs que la pêche européenne est
régie par des quotas appelés autrement
quantités maximales de pêche pour chaque
espèce chaque secteur et réparti entre
les États membres des règles visant à
éviter la surpêche mais certains pays
sont dans le collimateur de la
Commission de l'Espagne et la France en
tête pour non respect de ses règles les
enjeux sont colossaux car l'Union
européenne et le septième pêcheur
mondial est très fortement consommatrice
puisque premier importateur de produits
de la mer et avec ses 25 millions de
kilomètres carrés le domaine maritime de
l'Union européenne et le plus vaste au
monde la pêche Stop ou Encore et bien
pour en débattre deux invités Catherine
Chabot bonjour vous êtes membre
suppléante de la commission pêche ici au
Parlement européen navigatrice et vous
appartenez au groupe renoue le parti du
président Emmanuel Macron une Française
donc votre pays flirte avec l'illégalité
en ne respectant pas les quotas de pêche
et face à vous Nicolas Fournier un
défenseur des fonds marins en colère
directeur de campagne de l'ONG
Océana pour la protection de
l'habitatara la politique de pêche
commune la PCP est plus exactement a
rendu obligatoire de mettre fin à la
surpêche qui entamait trop nos stocks
évidemment de poissons elle est réputée
tout de même la plus protectrice du
monde est-ce que c'est encore vrai c'est
toujours vrai la politique dépêche
communes aujourd'hui un cadre
réglementaire qui est très ambitieux et
qui est une réussite on a
malheureusement l'Union européenne n'a
pas atteint ses objectifs de 2020 mais
il y a un progrès considérable qui a eu
lieu quand on regarde par rapport aux
années 2000 on a réduit drastiquement
les niveaux de surpêche notamment de
l'Atlantique donc c'est aujourd'hui on
sait ce qu'il faut faire respecter la
science adopter des quotas qui soit
proportionneux et on a des exemples
vraiment pertinents de stocks qui se
sont reconstitués donc on a on est sur
la bonne trajectoire on n'est pas encore
là on a dépassé cette échelon de cette
date de 2020 mais derrière ça le cadre
réglementaire est bon et la Commission
européenne la confirmé on a besoin
d'avoir beaucoup plus d'efforts sur la
mise en œuvre sur le contrôle le suivi
la conformité mais on sait ce qu'il faut
faire on a encore évidemment des points
de vigilance à avoir la Méditerranée par
exemple où il y a des taux de surpêche
qui sont importants mais la PCP
aujourd'hui comme on l'appelle dans le
jargon elle fonctionne cette politique
communicatrine Chabot malgré nos
systèmes de quota le que quand le comité
scientifique technique et économique de
la pêche de l'Union européenne nous
alerte vous alerte que la surpêche
concerne environ 30% des stocks de
poissons en Europe et vous disiez
Nicolas Fournier en Méditerranée on
parle de jusqu'à
85%, ce que vous trouvez pas que notre
système de réglementation il est quand
même défaillant voire hypocrite
là vous y allez fort je pense qui était
important de remettre la pêche
européenne dans un contexte plus large
plus international et effectivement il y
a des efforts à faire mais en
Méditerranée vous savez vous avez aussi
beaucoup de pêcheurs artisanaux de voilà
je sais que avec Nicolas on partage
certaines visions
notamment que quand on parle de la pêche
on imagine toujours les grands bateaux
de pêche mais voilà et je pense qu'il
faut penser alors moi j'ai pas les
chiffres sur la surpêche en Méditerranée
mais
en revanche moi j'insiste pour dire
qu'il faut arrêter de parler de la pêche
et
avec une catégorie et je pense qu'il y a
beaucoup d'efforts qui sont faits pour
arriver à gérer collectivement et quand
je vous dis qu'il faut avoir une vision
plus large il y a véritable sujet aussi
aujourd'hui sur lequel on avance malgré
tout c'est aussi la pêche illicite et la
pêche pratiquée par certains pays à
travers le monde pour ne pas les citer
notamment les Chinois moi le travail
notamment dans la commission aussi
développement où je suis titulaire et on
travaille sur vous savez les accords de
pêche que l'Union européenne signe avec
des pays tiers et c'est assez effrayant
de voir que sur les les bords des zones
des zones économiques exclusives de
certains pays vous avez des armadas
navires de pêche qui sont qui sont là
pour pour capter la ressource alors la
pêche la surpêche elle se joue au niveau
international et c'est vrai que l'Union
européenne comme comme le dit Nicolas a
fait beaucoup de progrès c'est
probablement vrai qu'il y a encore des
efforts à faire c'est vrai aussi dans
nos accords en effet nos accords avec
les autres régions du monde qu'il faut
qu'on impose aussi ce système ce
leadership en quelque sorte en matière
de pêche vous entendez cette idée que là
aussi il faut être vigilant et qu'on est
peut-être moins
c'est sûr que l'Union européenne est un
marché global c'est le premier marché
d'importation de poissons donc on a
aussi une on a une empreinte
internationale très forte parce qu'on a
des flottes externes qui pêchent dans
toutes les eaux du monde quasiment on a
la flotte française ou espagnole qui
sont très actifs par exemple dans le
salon indien sur les taux d'idées
malheureusement il y a nous ce qu'on
déplore c'est un peu un double discours
c'est qu'on a ce discours de champion et
de zéro tolérance sur la pêche illégale
comme vous l'avez souligné mais derrière
ça on peut blâmer les autres pays parce
que c'est vrai que les chinois sont
sûrement pas
exemplaires en termes de transparence
l'Union européenne a quand même un cadre
qui est important mais on a aussi nos
propres flottes qui ne respectent pas
ces règles qui sont la France et
notamment en infraction actuellement par
la Commission européenne sur cette
question de de marge de tolérance donc
c'est sur la flotte ton idée en dans
l'océan Indien donc c'est des énormes
bateaux c'est de la poche très
industrielle c'est des bateaux qui font
80 mètres et donc avant il faut aussi
avant de critiquer les autres balayer un
peu devant chez soi et et ses
problématiques parce qu'on a besoin que
les États la France et
[Musique]
qui vont à la mer et ça qu'est-ce qu'on
fait dans tous les États membres ou même
à travers le monde pour réduire les
pollutions qui vont à la mer ils sont
aujourd'hui
les premières impactés ou parmi les
premiers impacts des conséquences du
brexit des conséquences de la guerre en
Ukraine etc donc ils ont l'impression
plus le sujet qui ont peut-être abordé
sur le chalutage de fonds aujourd'hui
ils ont l'impression que ils sont
envahit toutes pas non je pense qu'il y
a certainement à balayer devant notre
porte comme le disait Nicolas et et des
choses à recadrer probablement dans
l'océan à dire alors vous parlez du
chalutage de fond le port de
Boulogne-sur-Mer était bloqué la semaine
dernière par les pêcheurs français il
protestent contre la restriction de la
pêche de fond par les saluts drags et
casiers mais les pêcheurs eux en effet
ils ont peur de la destruction de leur
emploi est-ce que vous le comprenez
c'est un faux débat en fait on parle on
parle Bernard in protégée donc les zones
les plus fragiles de nos océans et de la
technique de pêche la plus destructrice
la plus la plus climaticide donc en fait
il y a une incompatibilité qui est
reconnue au niveau international et en
fait en France notamment ou on essaie
justement de concilier on essaie d'avoir
cette approche ou ses compatible avec
une aire marine protégée c'est faux tous
les scientifiques vous le diront donc
aujourd'hui le problème des pêcheurs
emploie environnement
protégées donc c'est c'est quelques
pourcentages de l'autre côté le
pourcentage de 12 à 30% justement en
donc nous notre persécutive c'est que le
chat le chalutage de fond en fait les
européennes sont les os les plus
chalutés au monde et on est complètement
en décalage par rapport à nos ambitions
climatiques de protection de
l'environnement donc à terme le chalut
n'a plus sa place il va devoir
disparaître on va devoir d'échelle
utilisée nos flottes il faut le faire
progressivement parce qu'il y a des
enjeux sociaux économiques mais
commencez par les aires marines
protégées ça fait sens c'est les
endroits qu'on a désignés pour protéger
la biodiversité donc chaluter dans ces
zones c'est une incohérence écologique
et climatique et donc nous ce qu'on
demande c'est de le faire pas en 2030
c'est de le faire maintenant ensuite les
pêcheurs qui sont en grève si ils pèche
entièrement dans les arènes protégées il
y a un problème fondamental sur comment
est-ce qu'on a désigné ces arènes
protégées et là il y a un mensonge en
France encore plus quand on a proposé
des aires marines protégées on a
toujours dit au pêcheurs vous inquiétez
pas vous pourrez toujours continuer à
pêcher et donc quelque part on leur a
menti donc ils sont en colère et je
l'entends mais le problème c'est qu'on a
aussi une responsabilité politique
protégée on demande à n'importe qui tout
le monde dit bah c'est protégé donc il
faut un niveau de protection et pour
qu'elle fonctionne il faut qu'elle soit
protégée parce qu'une aire marine qui
n'est pas protégée donc une aire marine
de papier malheureusement c'est une
fausse protection ça concerne quand même
madame Chabot 7000 navires une flotte
européenne à la à la baisse puisque les
deux tiers de notre consommation de
poissons est importé c'est c'est
l'argument d'ailleurs des pêcheurs le
maintien de l'emploi le fait que de
toute façon s'il ne pêche pas on
emportera plus on pourrait dire aussi
ces aires marines protégées en Europe
s'il y a plus de poissons dans 10 ans il
y aura plus de pêcheurs non plus non
mais je suis complètement d'accord moi
je vais être totalement transparente je
ne suis pas alignée avec la position
française même si je suis alignée sur la
quasi-totalité des sujets que l'on porte
ici au Parlement européen j'ai beaucoup
m'interroger les scientifiques et même
ils vont beaucoup plus loin que les ONG
ils disent qu'à terme c'est le chalut de
fond qui est qui le faudrait il faudrait
engager fraîcheur dans un plan de déchet
d'utilisation et donc de commencer
effectivement comme l'a dit Nicolas
Fournier par les aires marines protégées
c'est pertinent après la problématique
et j'en discutais encore hier avec la
avec la commission la problématique
c'est qu'il faudrait pouvoir engager les
pêcheurs dans une véritable transition
coopère le transport maritime coopère
d'autres secteurs d'activité la
construction automobile je veux dire on
a des objectifs
parce que alors c'est peut-être
historique et culturel d'abord quand on
dit la pêche encore une fois on parle
toujours les pêcheurs sont représentés
en France surtout par une pêche plus
industrielle qu'on n'entend pas
forcément des plus petits et quand je
vous dis que c'est un peu culturel quand
on discute avec eux moi je discute avec
eux on est proche les pêcheurs on a
l'impression en plus avec le
développement des activités d'autres
activités en mer comme l'éolien offshore
ils étaient là avant ils ont
l'impression d'être complètement
encerclé etc donc il faut les
accompagner je sais que j'essaie d'avoir
une position
on va dire équilibrer mais j'insiste sur
le fait qu'il faut en même temps agir
sur le lien ternaire sur toutes ces
pollutions qui participent à la pression
sur la ressource parce que si on ne
montre pas au pêcheur qu'on travaille
aussi sur ces autres problématiques ils
ont l'impression qu'ils sont vraiment
les vilains petits canards et et voilà
après je pense que il y a peut-être
aussi de la mauvaise volonté peut-être
de certains et voilà non il y a un point
qui est quand même important pour
recadrer c'est que aujourd'hui le GIEC
de la nature donc le l'IPBS que
l'acronyme anglais précise clairement
que la pression principale de perte de
biodiversité en mer c'est la pêche donc
évidemment qu'il y a d'autres pressions
derrière mais la pêche c'est aussi une
activité qu'on contrôle directement si
demain on va mettre des quotas à des
niveaux scientifiques ou des niveaux de
précaution on peut le faire donc c'est
important de préciser cela parce que
évidemment c'est facile aussi les
pêcheurs faut souvent on l'entend le
changement climatique la pollution
plastique les rejets AG
évidemment mais la science nous montre
que la surpêche et l'activité c'est le
principal facteur de perte de
biodiversité donc c'est important de de
l'avoir en tête et de prendre
responsabilité et de dire ok il faut on
a on doit faire une transition
écologique et le plan d'action il est
bienvenu pour entamer cette transition
vers une pêche plus douce moins
énergivore plus sélective et on en a on
en a vraiment radicalement besoin et
partout parce qu'il y a peut-être aussi
d'autres éléments de contradiction et on
est en train d'essayer de renouveler un
accord avec le Maroc pour que 128
navires européens puissent continuer à
pêcher dans leurs eaux territoriales en
échange de plusieurs millions d'euros
est-ce que on peut dire que l'Union
européenne elle est en train d'organiser
un pillage légal des ressources en
poissons de pays plus pauvres
c'est un vaste débat c'est évidemment on
a on a je pense que la question de fond
c'est aussi la
l'approvisionnement en poissons du
marché européen ça fait des générations
qu'on pêche et qu'on a des accords de
pêche avec ses flottes qui opère au
large des côtes africaines dans l'océan
Indien et évidemment d'un point de vue
philosophique ça peut poser problème
aujourd'hui il faut se dire que l'Union
européenne le fait sous dans des cadres
d'accord de pêche qui sont les meilleurs
au monde entre guillemets qui sont
transparents on sait où va l'argent il y
a des conditions de développement local
on laisse aussi des avis scientifiques
pour laisser de la ressource au pêcheur
locaux c'est pas le cas des autres pays
qui pêchent dans par exemple dans dans
les pays d'Afrique donc la question elle
est plutôt de c'est plutôt philosophique
et c'est politique mais au bout d'un
moment il y a une transition à faire et
je pense qu'il faut impulser ces
réflexions sur est-ce qu'on a toujours
besoin de pêcher aussi loin et de et de
piller la ressource peut-être parce que
si la ressource se porte malle il faut
qu'on mette en question ça et
aujourd'hui la logique économique elle
est malheureusement on n'a pas le temps
de de de se poser la question mais je
pense que pertinent de se dire est-ce
qu'on a vraiment besoin d'aller pêcher
et de payer cette ressource
j'ai beaucoup travaillé dans en
commission Développement encore sur ces
fameuses accords de pêche il y a pas que
le Maroc il y a la Guinée-Bissau il y a
le Sénégal la Mauritanie de l'Ouest et
cetera et cetera donc il y en a beaucoup
et c'est vrai que quand on va sur place
on se rend compte que il y a une
contrepartie quand même à l'autorisation
de qui est donné à nos navires d'aller
dans les eaux
de ces pays là la contrepartie elle est
financière elle est censée aller et
c'est là où il faut véritablement qu'on
soit vigilant elle est aussi censée
aller à la filière et à aider par
exemple les femmes c'est beaucoup les
femmes qui se sont censé mais vous voyez
aussi le désarroi des pêcheurs
artisanaux sénégalais ou autre oui mais
je peux vous dire qu'ils sont bien plus
sous la pression des pêcheurs chinois et
moi je me dis si on n'est pas là c'est
une moi c'est un vrai sujet si on est
moi j'ai tendance à penser que il y a un
moment je me suis dit non faut arrêter
ces accords de pêche mais je trouve
qu'on a un vrai coopération qui est
beaucoup plus équilibrée que celle que
d'autres proposent je voudrais juste
revenir sur un point sur les arts
marines protégées l'interdiction du
chalut c'est pas pour éviter la surpêche
Nicolas il faut préciser c'est pour
préserver les habitats et préserver les
habitats qui ont aussi un rôle dans
l'équilibre du climat parce que par
exemple
je veux dire les ce qu'on appelle le
carbone bleu ces écosystèmes pour
lesquels je me bats beaucoup au
Parlement européen qu'on les reconnaisse
comme des comme les forêts terrestres
ces écosystèmes que sont les mangroves
que sont les herbiers les grandes algues
etc et les zones et les marais salées
marais salants etc doivent être
préservés et c'est plutôt vraiment ce
que l'on vise ce que vise à mon avis la
Commission européenne avec ce plan
d'action c'est la régénération du milieu
et de ce point de vue là je pense qu'il
faut absolument créer des zones
des réserves de réserves intégrales et
moi j'ai beaucoup défendu le modèle
français d'air marine protégée je crois
beaucoup à la au parc marin parce que
c'est de la construction mais la réalité
c'est c'est là où la problématique c'est
que la pression des pêcheurs fait que on
n'a pas on a interdit dans le parc marin
de la mer d'Iroise on ne fait plus on ne
va plus chercher les granulats comme on
dit allait mais on continue d'aller dans
le coeur de parc c'est un peu
contradictoire merci merci d'avoir très
bien illustré ce débat concernant la
pêche à très bientôt à tous restés sur
nos deux antennes
[Musique]